[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
is it already thursday
it's already thursday
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
it's thursday
newton eastern 11th central nine pacific
you know what time that is it's time for
let's talk to tony michael's podcast
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
now coming to you from facebook
on the midas touch
facebook page
live
stream
we're streaming we're streaming baby and
we're gonna surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends today
today we're going to surf those tweets
and the trends and boys there are a lot
of them apparently um uh true social has
[ __ ]
devin nunes diaper
i don't know and apparently speaking of
[ __ ]
speaking of [ __ ] ivermectin is a bunch
of horseshit well who could have guessed
that
oh my god
[Music]
we gotta do this cycle you notice this
we gotta do this cycle it's a
continuation
over and over and over again
i'm just this dumb stupid [ __ ] manga
[ __ ] right just this
this
just just the [ __ ] stupid it's just a
cycle of stupid it continues and
continues
and continues and continues
uh all year last year they're like
ivermectin good go down to the feed
store and get you some horse paste it
might give you the shits
but black god it cures some code
no
it didn't it won't it shouldn't it can't
it won't it isn't
they're like no do a study do a study on
it ladies big pharma didn't want you to
know but ivermectin is the cure for code
and then big pharma does
big huge study
and it's a big huge dud oh who'da
guessed
who'da guessed it
all that time these people are
protesting outside hospitals
they had to hire security to let [ __ ]
nurses and doctors walk from the
hospital to their car
the same doctors and nurses who are
trying to save people's lives last year
and this year
who weren't getting vaccinated who
thought i remember and boy that's the
way to go
well i i heard i heard i heard on
facebook the ivermectin institute
but that horse paste
is good [ __ ] that's good stuff
you just run on down to the tractor
supply and
pick you up some ivormectin it's that
big pharma that's against you
that doesn't tell you
that it's the cure for covered
i ivermectin
is made by big pharma you dumb [ __ ]
oh boy
i can't believe we just it's again we
have to cycle through the stupid over
and over and over again i mean we we
cycle back through the [ __ ] rush is
stupid
russia
if you're listening
if if you find the 30 000 hillary
clinton's email you remember that
[ __ ]
now it's
russia if you're listening
as long as you got time as long as
you're not murdering innocent women and
children in ukraine putin
will you help me
because i'm about to be indicted on
federal charges
please
find a way to
to get joe biden to step down and crown
me king get the [ __ ] out of here with
this nonsense dribble
holy [ __ ]
putin
murderous [ __ ] dictator
is committing war crimes against the
sovereign nation
he is killing innocent women and
children and families
in ukraine
because he's a psychopath
and the former president of the united
states is like you know what
you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to go on tv
well trader tv
i'm going to go on this this obscure
youtube kind of wish.com youtube channel
thing
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure
putin knows that i want his help
in the next election and the one after
that two
jesus [ __ ] christ
you know what putin if you're listening
release the [ __ ] p-tape already we
know that son of a [ __ ] exist
release the p-tape why we're getting
putin to release things why not [ __ ] why
not why not
we might as well
we might as well get that son of a [ __ ]
to release the p-tape if he were
listening if we have to make sure
that putin wins against democracy
and joe biden is dethroned as
his sleepy dictator of the united states
and donald trump is cap crown king we
might as well get a good look at this
p-tape
jesus [ __ ] christ
look
how in the [ __ ] how in the [ __ ]
do we expect i mean we watched the son
of a [ __ ] not run the country for four
years
four years we watched him not run the
country i mean he watched a lot of tv
he's good at the remote control
he can't they can't even they can't even
[ __ ] get true social
off the ground
like they [ __ ] copied and paste the
whole goddamn thing
the whole thing they copied and pasted
they just put a new [ __ ] paint job on
it and when i mean paint job they went
and bought three cans of spray paint
from the dollar store
holy [ __ ]
devin nunes left a very safe seat
in congress
uh to be the fall guy for the pump and
dump that is true social
holy [ __ ] and they're still like
pretending that it's a real thing that
it's gonna happen they're still
pretending like no no really it's um
uh next month the
well um
maybe by september 89th
we will have
true social up and running so you can
um download something like uh maybe
maybe you'll be able to get a pdf file
of what your account may appear like
like a promo example a demo of it
the [ __ ] out of here everyone's here
this morning good morning good thursday
morning everyone debbie from salt lake
robbins here jay is here kathy's here
amanda
is here ann is here daryl is here patty
we got a ton of people matt from
facebook jacqueline from facebook paula
facebook kaylee
facebook mj's here
well
we just got so many people thank you for
for tuning in
every single weekday monday through
friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
right here on youtube twitter twitch and
now coming to you live
from the midas touch facebook page so
don't forget to hit the like button
give us a comment
also subscribe to the uh the youtube
channel you don't want to miss a goddamn
thing
you do not want to miss a thing here
and if you do miss it it's okay because
it's over on youtube well i've got a few
banned episodes
there's a few of them that youtube's
like nah you can't say that tony
you can't say that
i don't i don't even really remember
what i said i think it's um
i have to go back and look at exactly
what episode but all the episodes all of
them
all of them are on apple so if you want
to download all the episodes they're all
there even the band ones that youtube
took off their the youtube channel
and then spotify has them too your
favorite boycotted directory
uh spotify they're over there as well
google anywhere where you download your
podcast they are there all of them
the banned ones no matter what i said
they're there they're there and boy are
they woke as disney have you seen this
these people are gonna boycott disney
apparently
they're boycotting disney there's
nothing better so i i we planned on
taking our kids to disney this year i
was like let's you know covers past you
know maybe maybe we'll take the kids to
disney this year the greatest part about
it is manga is boycotting disney i'm
like yeah this is [ __ ] great perfect
year to take them to disney
perfect [ __ ] year these people are
gonna boycott
orlando boycott
the the disneyland in california at
fantastic
that'd be awesome you might be able to
walk around and
not have to you know smell the [ __ ] that
they're stepping in
it's fantastic i think it's a wonderful
thing that they're boycotting disney
theme parks
yeah sure why not let's
i wish they would boycott a hell of a
lot more things don't you
especially like out in public maybe they
should boycott public in general that
would help they used to do that like
these neo-nazis these white supremacists
you know they'd hide underneath their
rocks
they wouldn't come out in public
as it were
they would uh they would stay dormant
[Laughter]
the white supremacists would stay
dormant
they wouldn't come out to play
so so i mean i'm encouraging more and
more trump pumping idiots spread knicks
these ivermectin uh goblin
fools
to boycott all kinds of stuff
go ahead be my guest especially again
things in public
uh midas lisa thank you very much
for the super chat
she says hey tony thanks for fighting
daily for democracy every single weekday
lisa new eastern 11 central right here
on youtube twitter and twitch and if
you're on youtube
if you're on youtube don't forget we
have the super chat like minus lisa has
here you can do a super super sticker or
super chat
if you come over to the youtube page so
all of you on facebook if you want to
watch they're great
but if you want to come over to the
youtube page
you can give a super sticker we're also
on twitch
everyone's out there there's people
still on watching us on twitch we're
still there
uh
look at smituskin gives the super
sticker the layup
the layup with the super sticker in the
chat thank you midaskin
and for all of you listening out there
on the podcast directories
apple spotify google wherever you're
listening i heart radio give us a five
star review out there but also you might
want to come
come participate when you can in the
live chat
you type in a little typie type and i
might just bring it up on the screen as
well
thank you thank you midas lisa and
midaskin
for the super chat and the super sticker
we have jamie here we have kathy frank
is here from facebook
yoda is here jamie's here midas stacy
hello
great job keep up the great work you too
midas stacy you too
thank you very much for joining us i
think gabe is going to join us at the
bottom of the hour we have some we have
some news we have some news about uh
about bone head madness
some big
breaking heist news
that's right
that's right there's been a heist
at the bonehead madness and i think
we're gonna go over that i think gabe
gabe gabe is a little upset
about what has happened with the
bonehead madness heist
we have a heist on our hands
and he's going to address the heist news
yeah there's news there's big bonehead
madness news folks so you don't you
won't want to go anywhere for this
gabe's going to join us at the bottom of
the hour as normal
and he's going to give us the bonehead
heist news mj mj mj thanks for the super
sticker mj
mj's here every single weekday she is
here
she is here every single weekday thank
you mj for the super sticker
big news big bonehead madness news did
you guys go vote in the bonehead madness
poll
did you guys go select who you want the
winners you know we do bonehead of the
week every single week
and and what we do is we do a poll we
put a poll up for all you new listeners
out there on on the twitter page at
tonymichaelspot so go follow us there so
you can vote for bone end of the week
we're going to put that bonehead of the
week poll up this afternoon but this
week is a special week
in the bonehead category because gabe
has a game going called bonehead madness
over at tony michael's pod twitter page
where you get to vote there's games
every single day we are to the
semifinals folks
the semi finals
so we'll announce today who's in the
semifinals who will compete to win the
bonehead madness champion
and then tomorrow
because every single friday in the
second hour we go over the bonehead of
the week poll we go through your vote
you vote
we discuss
on the second hour the tony michaels
podcast every single week for bonehead
of the week
this week is a special edition because
we have bonehead madness
so be sure to go to at tony michael's
pod today
and participate in the semi-finals for
the bonehead madness champion
but again oh boy we have a bonehead
madness heist
and we have some news
for you
we have some news for you
so let's let's uh let's go to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends i know you
guys want to get to this let's see what
what do we get
what do we got trending today folks
um what what is what's on the trendy
trends in the tweety tweets it was a
little light this morning
um you know other than the former guy
colluding with uh putin in russia
we have gas prices on the list that the
strategic
pattoli but petroleum reserve there i
said it right
maxine waters is trending
trans day of visibility
trans day of invisibility is trending
devin nunes is trending
because he's a dumb ass
of course why else would devin nunes
trend
could you think of another a better
reason why
i mean i can't think of one boycott
disney hashtag boycott disney is
trending i'm all up in that one let's do
that let's get him to boycott all kinds
of [ __ ]
uh hashtag trump cover-up midas touch
has a new video out trump cover-up we'll
play that here he knows you guys know
we're partnered with midas touch but
it's a great video it's a fantastic
video about the seven hour gap between
trump's head oh i mean that that the
phone records
not not his not his hollow [ __ ] his
hollow skull it's the phone records the
the seven hour phone records that's what
it is jared kushner and chris ray is
trending as well
along with
along with the the famous
the famous
coveted treatment ivermectin
ivermectin is trending
so let's let's have us an ivermectin
cocktail
and let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the shitless roundup the part
of the show where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends of
the day this is our favorite part
normally this takes up the whole damn
show just because the [ __ ] list is so
[ __ ] long here lately and it'll
continue to be long as long as we don't
get some of these indictments and
convictions happening
we really we really need to clean up the
trash in this country don't we holy [ __ ]
the garbage heap is huge
oh my god
let's see let's go through the timeline
real quick here uh what do we what do we
what do we got here would we let's make
this a little bigger let's make this a
little bigger
so you folks out there can see
now rachel bitkoffer you know that she's
one of our favorite here
on the tony michaels podcast she appears
almost every single week let's see was
rachel gonna come on today
oh sh she might she says she might here
let me uh
we're gonna we're gonna invite uh rachel
here to the
to the show
um that way
that way
give me just one second
all right we'll see if we can get rachel
on here in just a little bit
uh she says it is a change quote unquote
election folks
you must disqualify the change in other
words
don't you don't wanna you don't wanna
change
here uh if you wanna i mean you can have
a change think about the change you're
gonna have
think about the change you're gonna have
ron desantis
a don't say gay bill and trust me when i
say this
trust me when i say this ron desantis
and florida's don't say gay bill
that's gonna be the light version of
what these other states are going to try
to do
right that's the light version
because there's going to be a ton of
other states
in line to out florida florida for
[ __ ] sure 100 percent
it ain't going to quit with florida
it ain't gonna stop they're gonna
they're gonna try to ostracize everyone
that we have we have more i i'm gonna
show you a picture today that i
retweeted
of governors signing anti-trans bills
and i'm going to show you i'm going to
show you the the the the
the girls that they're talking about
in these anti-trans bills i'll show you
we're going to show you uh midas touch
tweets here true social has suffered a
93 decline in its download since launch
and is a massive flop have a nice day
have a nice day
have a good one
have a good one devin nunes
piece of [ __ ]
speaking of devin nunes uh mayo says i'm
starting to think devin nunes quit
congress to help trump want her money
through true social
uh well i don't think he's helping i
actually think he's just the fall guy do
you think devin nunez is smart enough to
know he's the fall guy of true social do
you think he's smart enough to know that
i don't know
i don't know
i don't believe so i don't believe so uh
heather gardner here and we've had
heather on the show
as a guest you guys can go check that
out on youtube
on our channel
we interviewed heather
about her videos
and some of her some of the content that
she creates
she says she's talking about the don't
say gay bill here she says i've been
incredibly concerned
with the flippant way republicans use
grooming quote unquote when talking
about the don't say gay bill
gay doesn't equal pedophile this is the
[ __ ] that marjorie taylor green was
saying on stage you remember this
remember this [ __ ] where she said
she said pete but a judge and her
husband going in little girls bathrooms
the [ __ ] is she talking about that's
what they're saying
look this is all [ __ ] code language i
keep hearing this [ __ ] i keep
hearing this [ __ ] nonsense where
they're like it doesn't say don't say
gay in the bill he doesn't say that
he doesn't say those words stop calling
it that well here's here's the rub
here's the great part about it
democrats won the messaging on that bill
now we didn't win the game meaning
ron desantis and the republicans in
florida need to be voted out
we need to get the [ __ ] bigots out of
our goddamn governments everywhere
local state federal we need to get the
[ __ ] bigots out
it's enough of this [ __ ] stupid-ass
[ __ ]
where they're trying to ostracize people
not let people be free and equal in
society
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
heather says besides only one group is
really grooming quote unquote our kids
and it's not the rainbow flag crowd
let's uh let's listen to heather's
report here injecting sexual instruction
what are essentially grooming centers
for gender identity radicals wow it's
almost like they want people to
associate being gay with being a
pedophile but since they're so obsessed
with the gay community infiltrating
their kids at schools let's chat about
florida's o.g grooming tactic brought to
you by christians when i was a student
in florida i was told to bring my bible
to school to convert my friends to team
jesus parents in my bible belt county
successfully petitioned the school board
to present evolution lessons as just a
theory because it contradicted
creationism my public school sex
education was abstinence only
accompanied by the wildly popular true
love weights curriculum
promoted by the southern baptist
convention there's definitely people
injecting certain agendas into our kids
all right but it ain't the rainbow flag
crowd
hills to the no it ain't
and it ain't gonna quit either they've
been doing this for years and what the
[ __ ] i keep saying i keep asking this
question and no one will [ __ ] answer
it for me no one will answer this
question for me why are republicans
why are they so [ __ ] obsessed with
other people's genitalian bathrooms
why
[ __ ] weirdos i i have never i have
never in my life went into a goddamn
bathroom
and and and
thought about the person's genitalia in
the stall next to me and is [ __ ]
gross and weird and creepy
republicans stop stop obsessing about
other people's genitalia and by the way
while i'm on this [ __ ] subject
while i'm on this [ __ ] subject
just because someone's gay that doesn't
have anything to do with sex you dumb
[ __ ]
if
hear me out here
hear me out
hear me out when a when a straight white
dude like me christian
i'm not i'm i'm just it's hypothetical
i'm not a christian but someone who
looks like me who's a christian who's
got a christian wife old christian why
no one no one says their genders have
anything to do with sex
not a [ __ ] word not a [ __ ] peep
not a god damn peep
do those does that couples genders have
anything to do with sex
not a goddamn thing
you get you get [ __ ] you get two men
two women
a trans man and a man a trans woman and
a woman you get them
in a couple oh by god that's all it has
to do with is sex
sex sex sex sex they can't think about
anything but other [ __ ] people's
genitalia
and sex
they're [ __ ] they're absolutely
they're absolutely obsessed about other
people's genitalia and other people's
sex lives which
being gay
exclusively about sex you dumb [ __ ]
it's a it's about someone loving someone
someone wanting to be with someone
someone wanting to partner with them
maybe marry him maybe date him maybe
[ __ ] him i don't know
what the [ __ ] is it any of your goddamn
business anyways
and when a kindergartner or a first
grader has two [ __ ] moms
our two dads
what is it any of your [ __ ] business
what what you can and can't define their
moms and their dad's relationship as you
[ __ ] weirdos
stop worrying about other people's
[ __ ] genitalia it's weird it's gross
and people don't want to [ __ ] hear
about it anymore
we're we're sick and tired of you
telling us what the [ __ ]
what how what kind of genitalia you can
have in your pants what kind of
genitalia can be in this bathroom or
that bathroom
who you can and can't love who you can
and can't [ __ ] marry who you can and
can't date who you can can't [ __ ] we're
tired of the fastest [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop telling the rest of us what the
hell we can and can't do
it's enough of that [ __ ]
enough of it and that's exactly what
that [ __ ] bill does
it's exactly what it does you know it's
it's it's hidden over the guise of well
we're trying not to sexualize children
you're sexualizing children by
sexualizing a relationship that their
parents may have
or or
thoughts that they may have do you
understand that a kindergartner doesn't
even [ __ ] know the difference between
a foot the full difference between a
gender you dumb [ __ ] i this is the other
thing too this is really bugging the
[ __ ] out of me people this is really
bugging the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me this
question what's a woman
what's a woman
what's a woman
well what's a woman
and these
and liberals give a really shitty answer
here
liberals are like well um
uh a woman is uh
uh well a woman
a woman i i'm not a i'm not a biologist
but uh
and i'm not a dictionary i i
yeah
i don't i don't go around fine shut the
[ __ ] up listen a woman you want to know
what a woman is it's a gender that a
person identifies as
there's all sorts of [ __ ]
identifications of a woman as well all
kinds all kinds and you know whose
[ __ ] business it is that person who
identifies as a [ __ ] woman
why why are liberals so [ __ ] scared
to say that why why are you so [ __ ]
scared to say that it is a gent of what
when someone asks you when some dumb
[ __ ] comes up to you the next
time you see them and you and they say
what's a woman what's a woman there liv
[ __ ] what's a woman tell me what i want
you know they're trying to get you right
they're trying to trap you in this thing
well because liberals don't wanna they
don't wanna rock the woke boat right
especially get caught on camera like i
am right now yelling into a microphone
with thousands of people listening
they don't want to get caught
they want to be woke as [ __ ] or woke as
disney either one
but it's really [ __ ] simple it's not
hard
you want it you want to know the
definition to a woman
earl
a woman is gender that a person
identifies as and there's a shitload of
identities that that person who chooses
to identify a woman could take
under the guise of a woman or a man or
whatever
and when a dude ask you that when a when
a hetero when a hetero white male
ask you that [ __ ]
you ask them as soon as you say that you
say so you identify as a man right
just throw it right back at him throw it
right back at him get get throw it right
back at him [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense that question and why
liberals can't answer that [ __ ]
question
it's really dumb
it really is bugging the [ __ ] out of me
so say gay say it a lot
don't be
republicans
don't be scared of gay people
they're just human beings like yous and
bees
they just they just may like
to love a different person than you you
dumb [ __ ] they're not telling you who
you should love
and stop
stop worrying about other people's
[ __ ] genitalia and bathrooms stop it
it's weird
it's really
really [ __ ] gross creepy and weird
okay let's uh let's move on here
oh we're gonna get back to the trans
thing here in a minute
now the trans people the trans persons
they're they're banning uh trans
women from men's sports or trans uh
boys from girls sports they're doing
that so
we'll get to that they're they're being
fascist there as well
oh dan says here former president trump
was publicly aligning himself with the
hostile nation of russia to undermine
our sitting president
it's not
normal no it's it's not and it's
anti-american as we've seen it this is
this this is his
anti-american as this [ __ ] has
gotten
in this moment
because of what putin is doing to
democracy around the world and what he's
the
the the war crimes and the murdering
that he's
committing in ukraine donald trump will
never make america great
and he's not even pretending anymore
thank you dan for your tweet everyone
spread this tweet around like it's
herpes thank you dan
uh
aaron aaron's partner says here uh we
cannot uh let the world forget that
russian state tv called donald donald
trump their partner
and asked russians to help re-elect him
in 2024 and he's really [ __ ]
desperate by the way holy [ __ ] they're
on like tv like please
please we gotta
we gotta have trump win in 2024
or putin's really [ __ ]
yeah he truly is okay here's um
here's some more news about the uh um
don't say gay bill uh midas touch posted
this video here um it's a report from
florida uh it looks like people are
taking notice of our billboards that are
currently across florida let's uh let's
watch this real quick
and you can see the billboards here that
say say people in orlando have their
eyes on this new billboard on alafaya
trail on east colonial drive that
encourages people to say gay it's okay
to say gay it's more than okay it's
encouraged ali sammarco is a volunteer
on the project that's spearheaded by the
left-leaning southern progress pact that
promotes progressive policies through
legislation we want to make it very
clear that it's okay to talk about you
know who you are and where you come from
and that no one can stop you from doing
that this billboard just went up in
orlando but it's not the only one in
florida there's also one in tallahassee
and jacksonville and another one goes up
in miami this week i never want kids
especially kids at such a young age to
feel
weird or different or made to feel like
there's something wrong with them and i
think that it's important to show them
from a very young age that it's okay to
be yourself
in orlando harley martinez wesh 2 news
okay so you see the the billboards going
up in
in florida around florida it seems like
minus touch is probably partnering you
know we're partnering with minus touch
but minus just seems to be partnering
with that uh we we have we have someone
joining us uh gabe how are you today
oh you know
uh
you're you're a little pissed off today
about a bonehead madness heist i hear
yeah
what's going on over there who who is
heisted the bonehead madness um uh
what what is it what do we say what do
we say here
uh who i mean
okay look i'll just put it out there i'm
not happy with lincoln project okay okay
oh
shots across the back
is the third time
they have taken content
from me they have taken an idea and then
they tried to execute on it and they've
done their own version whether it was
done
poorly or not the idea is
[Laughter]
i did it there's evidence they copied it
so you got time stamps and everything i
got time stamps baby i sent you links we
got some links we got some links here
that we're going to look at so just to
be clear for so everyone knows um we we
we did this uh
uh uh competition gay i didn't say we i
mean gabe um i definitely i i i
i say bonehead a lot and that's probably
my biggest contribution to it oh i did
pick out
[ __ ] waffles yeah you guys that was me
that i i i did the waffle
um what do you call it the the round
yeah the region yeah the region the
waffle region that that was me so i i
contributed that but gabe pretty much uh
as usual with all the graphics and
everything and did the rest
and with bonehead because gabe the
bonehead of the week thing really has
kind of been your thing since we started
it um you know that that we did this
bonehead thing yeah and you've had this
idea for quite some time with the
bonehead madness this is not just
something new that you just came up with
you've been working on this for quite a
while um i definitely i definitely tease
it out there you know couldn't be march
madness you know right right right hey
hey we can't say march madness don't
don't we can't say that we can't say
that we can say gay though gay gay gay
gay gay gay gay gay gay that's right
well we can't say we can't say march mad
because it's not it's bone right man
it's bonehead madness now you come up
with this bracket system because you
know there is a certain basketball
tournament that happens during march so
you thought we might do something
similar with the boneheads yeah why not
like we do with bone hand of the week
right and and by the way um who why
we're talking about that who is in the
semifinals
uh the semi-finals uh are between uh
tucker carlson and marjorie taylor green
what
yeah
no no no no no i
i think i don't think it was marjorie
taylor green was it did she not win did
she did yeah i i'm telling you i think
there's an upset i oh boy i think
there's i made this
did i not look oh it was ron desantis
ron desantis with the don't say gay bill
comes in at the end
comes in at the end and dunks
when i went to bed last night they were
two hours left in the poll and marjorie
taylor green had 55 percent and ron
desantis had 45. yeah he
[ __ ] flipped it on her i did man
totally run down
full court press slam dunk the ball talk
about a comeback story well this is what
happens this is what happens when you
sign stupid [ __ ] legislation like a
don't say gay bill you you end up you
end up beating you end up beating a
bonehead like marjorie taylor green
which is a difficult feat in and of
itself i think we sound like a sports
show now we should know hey we've gone
down the court the full corporate uh
yeah it's that is crazy yeah when i went
to i shared it a little bit more last
night before i bet before i went to bed
because i was like oh you know i'll get
the word out and mind you this was again
there are two hours left on this thing
so i was like oh this is pretty much oh
she like retweeted it or something or
yeah i like shared it to a few people
and then got it oh okay so i got more
votes but yeah i looked at it last night
and i was like
so what's what's the tally there what's
the tally there then for that for that
game that we had what what did it ended
up being so it was uh rhonda let me see
if i can find it while you're talking
yeah yeah ron desantis 56.1 marjorie
taylor green 43.9
ted cruz
47.3 percent tucker carlson 52.7 so
it's against the uh
you know the fascist bros tucker carlson
and ron desantis
let's see where where are we at here
my oh i'm not at the top and that's why
we gotta go to the top baby let's see
let's see let's see let's see what we
got here what we got oh here it is
here's here's the one we're talking
about
game two of deplorable four between
marjorie taylor green and ron desantis
marjorie taylor green man she had 55
rhonda santa's flipped at some you were
right
just turned it on its head yeah it was i
mean like i said when you pass bigoted
fascist legislation to ostracize a
certain group of people from society to
shame
to shame people to shame children and
their parents
when you do [ __ ] like that boy you
really do turn it around i mean
it is uh if you're if you're going for
bonehead ron desantis boy are you in the
right you are in the right lane you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he won
he won so we have ron desantis and
tucker carlson yeah so i got to update
the uh i got to update the graphics for
that okay good good well um
uh congratulations to ron desantis for
being for for winning against marjorie
taylor green the undefeated marjorie
taylor green and bonehead i don't think
she's actually lost a bonehead since
we've had her on has she i don't think
no she's pretty much won bonehead every
time she's been in the running right
she's i don't think she's ever lost
she's pretty much undefeated i mean she
is she's tough to beat in a bonehead
pole she is tough to beat but boy he
came in at the last hour there
um so let's talk a little more though
about that about the heist but yeah yeah
yeah let's talk about it so yeah i'm
sure people want to know the t you want
me to spill the tea well um so it has to
do with the lincoln project and it has
to do with um
this uh video
then i'm gonna pull up hang on just one
second let me let me grab it here i
think this is the video here and this is
a lincoln project video that we're gonna
play
um and what is it called it's called
maga madness is that what it's called
that's what it's called it seem and they
even have the hashtag it seems
it seems a little yeah i don't know like
uh lifted or something let's see let's
stay just they just they released it
yesterday or whatever so
well let's let's look at it here the
mega final four is set after a bitter
and often deranged battle to this point
who moves to the title game whose convoy
will show up in support who's house
magus house and now four stand out the
best of those who play the worst all
operating well below the rim when they
go low we're like
damn they really went there but here
they are and the competition is fierce
the first semi-final pitch actual
elected congresswoman marjorie now look
here look here
marjorie taylor green is in the running
is in the running let's let's keep
listening three taylor green versus
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
pitting them again
dominated the colt 45 region the cult 45
region wait a second wait a second that
that sounds familiar like they're naming
regions
gabe
interesting that sounds familiar well i
i lost it there
i don't know what the hell happened
let's go back to the
the coal 45 region
yeah
there we go all right let's keep playing
dominated the colt 45 region she knocked
off ohio's josh mandel in her opener
before just sparring rudy four seasons
giuliani and easily dismissing venmo
user matt gates and stadium
you know what's funny about this you
know what's funny about this is
they they actually just decided who who
it was yeah it seems like we were much
more engaged you mean in a more
democratic way right right right like
actually voting uh and having having a
say in the process of who actually
becomes the bonehead of the week it
really does seem like they just decided
you know what hey that looks like a
really good idea someone's doing let's
make a video and let's not let other
people decide while we make this right
right let's go ahead and just steal it
the whole thing and just make a video
let's continue three names is up against
mitch mcconnell the veteran has lost his
step but always relies on his worst
instincts as he displayed an easy wins
over lindsey graham russia ron johnson
and sarah huckabee the duchess of
arkansas mitch will likely waddle the
ball up the court but marge is a real
sniper and she constantly dunks on
herself that's enough to make her the
true leader of the republican party and
with russian bot support too much for
ole miss to stay with the second semi
features cia reject tucker swanson
carlson repping the outraged machinery
he mowed through glenn beck alex jones
and sean hannity to face off next
against first ballot hall of fame least
like humans ever ted fruit
he picked up sorry that's right
so are they are they are they actually
they're not only
stealing heisting the whole bonen they
are stealing the actual bracket itself
yeah
wait a second wait so they literally
took uh took our your graphic
the tony michaels podcast graphic they
took they took the graphic and they were
like this is really good yeah make a
video and they just say hey dude they
just [ __ ] copy paste
they just like oh you know who uh we
should have marjorie taylor green go off
against lauren beaubert and then we
should have matt gates go against
marjory taylor green we should have sean
hannity go against tucker carlson we
should have tucker carlson go against
ted cruz i'm sorry people we have the
receipts
go to our twitter account and look at
the receipts every day is updated with
the graphic of where the poll is and
where
the the rankings stand
i'm just saying everyone's blaming
george conway in here but you have
someone else that you want to get on the
show yep to try to to try to uh sort
this out who would you like to wilson
oh you think you think you think rick
wilson is responsible for the thing i
don't know
all the way to the top i want rick
wilson and whoever else is in charge of
uh approving this content that goes out
right and then i want to talk to whoever
is lifting this [ __ ] from me yeah well
you know
because you have more than just this
right yeah i got two more i got okay
two more
pieces of evidence to enter into the
court
okay well i'll be the the judge and the
jury here um which one do i do first
here i guess it doesn't matter um uh
start no no you want to start with the
scream video so show mine then show
theirs then then
um
okay this is this is on instagram
looks like
so i'm i'm leaving twitter everyone oh
bro
okay so let me set up context here now i
have a series of videos that i created
and i probably will bring back to some
extent uh i had a
voter call center guy and he would call
different people and have conversations
with them around the upcoming election
so what i did was i took famous scenes
from movies where the person was on the
phone and the person was like hey i'm
calling from the voter you know just
remember to vote blah blah blah and i'm
splicing in a conversation with the
actual movie so i did that for like
nine or ten videos from right and you've
done more videos like this like you've
taken trump trump's name you splice in
but you specifically did a movie series
with the the dog yeah yep i did anchor
man i did tropic thunder i did scream i
did the ring i did uh
anchorman
uh i did i don't know if i'd already
said it uh yeah you already said that
yeah yeah it's stream dude did you do
stream no i didn't i i yeah i did scream
yeah did you do screen i did sure
i'm pretty sure yeah yeah what about
anchorman
yeah anchorman yeah third time's the
charm i did uh get out another one
uh i believe i did taken
um
so what's the one we're gonna watch here
so the one we're gonna watch right now
is the very first one this one is scream
okay so it's the opening scene with drew
barrymore on the phone making the
popcorn
okay so here here is the
let's take the banner down i want to
make sure we get all we get all the
evidence
um very appropriate look at we look well
there's no time on the timestamp outside
of october 14th 2020. keep that in mind
october 14th
of 2020.
hello hi are you ready to vote who is
this this is john from vote or die i got
a minute i don't think
what's that noise popcorn i'm starving
right now uh-huh management doesn't let
us eat on the clock well i'm getting
ready to watch a video a campaign video
oh just some scary movie are you sure
it's on the trump campaign video uh-huh
who's your favorite presidential
candidate i don't know who are you ken
bone this is 20 20. you have a favorite
guy in the white mask who walks around
and stalks babysitters maybe that's a
trunk of you i mean he'd never wear a
mask but the babysitter parked that
lines up what's yours my favorite got
killed off in the second act so i'm
voting for biden
okay so that is your video that is you
know short sweet to the point boom done
right okay so let's let's go to let's go
to
the um
so this is the link what they did is
they took the same scene but they
started splicing in lindsey graham's
audio which i don't think it went a
little too long and i don't think it
really played to the effect but we'll
watch okay here we go
hello
i want to give you my side of the story
who is that so they're not
doing jump cuts they're just doing this
audio okay let's get on our websites
lindseygram.com
i don't think so
i'd like to know where the hell some of
it's coming from popcorn there's a lot
of money uh-huh
let's go
why you want to ask me out on a date
every liberal in the country wants to
take me out you just need to be
conservative not liberal
why do you want to know my name i'm
being killed financially it really
doesn't even make sense does it nope
i'm getting out raised three to one i
mean not just not just the script but
that they stole it from me doesn't make
sense either but but the script doesn't
really make sense
that's not what you said that's not your
problem
help me
this money is because they hate my guts
look i gotta go
i don't know what's going on out there
i don't think so they're loading me up
help
yeah okay so what's the date on this oh
look at the date
look at the date everybody october 16
2020.
how many days after you made your posted
your video is that how many days
two days but i think
i think the actual time was less than
two days but oh okay because it because
but but it's true
yeah mm-hmm here okay
hmm
interesting so personally for me
obviously i'm subjective to my own
content but i look at that and i say
there were probably two lines in the
total
that
maybe connected the rest
was like trying to force feed its way in
uh to make it work so let's look at this
one this the date on this post this is
your post right yeah now yeah 13 days
later
okay i make another video
what movie is this this is the ring okay
and and and this is the same type of
video where you're doing jump cuts
mm-hmm yep
with the call it's same premises before
just a different movie exactly let's
let's let's watch gabe's video here
oh sorry about that there we go
[Laughter]
so we see we see but during the ring
when they're watching the tv you put all
the the the crazy trump's
exactly so typically in the movie
there's a bunch of like creepy stuff and
like bodies and worms and stuff and i
replace that with just a bunch of videos
of trump which are inherently creepy so
right right right okay
sorry about that been on the phone all
day with voters just want to remind you
that it's seven days till the election
and make sure to vote for biden
that's that's it yeah super simple yeah
so just right to the chase when when she
answers the phone there's only a one
liner
and you have all the trump stuff on the
tv okay so now we're gonna now we're
gonna watch
the lincoln project yeah a video that
they posted on instagram and for if i
check my records correctly
uh
the time stamp because this one was
posted on the very same day okay okay
now
i posted
my version on 10 27 2020 at 2 p.m
they posted their version on 10 27 2020
at 8 15 p.m
so just keep that in mind so there's six
hours between these now now
now also um this is the ring as well
obviously um so we're gonna let's there
we go let's see we can play this one
here
yeah my opponent has raised more money
than anybody
help me lindsey graham.com they're going
crazy
help me
so that's it and that's it
that's it just the same the same premise
where they just
they lift the idea they throw the
lindsey graham
uh voiceovers over they even take
your idea
of posting the video on the tv
mm-hmm um in this case instead of trump
they used to but
it's going nuts you need to get on the
internet right now my opponent has
raised more money than anybody they use
lindsey graham there so that's the same
audio that they used in the screen video
oh my god keep that in mind as well so
we got one posted on 10 14 then another
one posted on 10 16. then we got mo you
know mine posted on 10 14. they were
posted on 10 16. mine posted on 10 27 at
2 p.m and there is posted on 10 27 at 8
15 p.m
so
and here's the thing the only reason i
knew that these videos existed was
because i was getting messages from
people that were like oh i didn't know
you were working with the lincoln
project and i was like what are you
talking about and then they're like oh
dude did you see the video here and they
sent me the video and i go
no i
i didn't know about this
so this is so these these two videos
was last year and this
okay this manga madness this manga
madness
uh yeah that's right two years ago holy
[ __ ] well i guess like a year and a half
right it was october
but this bag of madness is the third
time
the third time it seems as if the
lincoln project has lifted your id is
that correct
yeah yeah
maybe maybe instead of the lincoln
project they should be called the
lifting project
ah
this is
if if no one is aware um gabe works
really hard over there with these videos
i mean it's not it's not easy you know
he just doesn't uh throw this you know
the wigs and everything in the
background this [ __ ] is planned right
for a while you know i gotta you know i
got other things go i got work and other
responsibilities and things i gotta do
so i can't right he's got a stream soda
he's gotta get tacos i mean this guy's
gonna make it on soda water it's crazy
right it's crazy over there there's a
lot of manufacturing of
soda water and
and here the lincoln project and rick
wilson is
um lifting ideas uh from the famous gabe
sanchez we are three for three they're
really going for that hat trick i see
[Laughter]
gabe is not happy folks if you no if you
haven't i'm not happy
so the lincoln project i just want to
put the lincoln project right is a
huge group with a lot of money that's
right
you know what you read to what you see
about where they spend that money and
what their actual priorities are in
terms of just getting trump out to bring
back the republican party mm-hmm you
know whatever but
if a big group like that
is just oh you know what i'm just gonna
swipe that idea i'm just gonna copy that
idea and it doesn't execute it it's like
why wouldn't you just say hey this is a
good idea we'll pay you either for the
rights to play this video or we'll pay
you to write other ideas for us
and you post them uh we'll post them on
your behalf like it just make it just
makes total sense that you would go that
route as opposed to
i'm gonna steal this idea and then i'm
just not gonna execute on it well again
i'm subjective so if people disagree you
know that's what you have your own
opinion but i believe
that
they did a very shitty lazy job of
copying and poorly executing a joke
um
on their end so you know
we can't all be comedians
well here's here's what i'll tell you is
that anyone out there if you if you go
to the lincoln projects page and you go
to the maga madness video because i i i
thought the manga madness video was a
decent video i thought it was i'm not
saying yeah
it was decently executed it was decently
executed
but i will tell you if anyone out there
um especially gabe's fans here at the
tony michaels podcast
my suggestion is that you go over to
lincoln project's page you know a lot of
people oh what you don't want to do now
what you do want to do is go over there
what you do want to do is go over there
and tell them how you feel about the the
the so-called heist yeah and if you're
gonna do that if you're gonna do that
yeah make sure
uh to
take our tweet that's right and post it
as a comment and say like
you know i have much so much more enjoy
this and and tag and tag the podcast tag
me make sure to tag george conway rick
wilson
uh reed uh schmidt tag them all
tag them all if you want to get their
attention and help gabe out here because
everything they're all welcome on this
show yeah no i i i welcome on i i do
have uh i will say this my main priority
outside of discussing politics is to
address this issue because here's the
thing there are no such things
as a coincidence okay like it doesn't
happen like oh that that was odd that
was so similar no no especially not
three times no no no no this is
something where
uh it there was something
to put in
mj says post split screens
i don't know that you might we might
want to
you know
get the court more evidence here maybe i
don't know
um but
it is it is do you see the
i'm talking to the audience here and
really honestly if you if you're just
listening to podcast come on the youtube
channel and watch this part of the show
um because you definitely want to see
the two videos uh
you know the games video and then
lincoln projects video
um but but gabe is calling out rick
wilson
right here live on air and lincoln
project itself but rick
rick if you're listening
come on the show let's talk about it
yeah let's talk about it somebody's got
to approve this content and i want to
know who it is and i want to know who
the creator of the content is
wilson knows i wouldn't sure i'm sure
you know like i can't imagine that rick
wilson just like yeah you guys post
whatever you want someone has
someone is reviewing this content made
by some content creator so i want to
know who is watching my stuff
and who is copying it and then once it's
posted like who is approving that post
you know right so so let me ask you does
rick follow your account any of your
accounts do you know no i do know that
he's fallen for my trump announcements
before though oh has he oh so
[Laughter]
so wait a second so wait a second what
you're saying is
uh
because you pissed daniel could you
release another one it didn't it didn't
yeah it didn't you know i tried to get
you to do a certain thing and you
wouldn't do it to really piss people off
i know i know i i
i almost did it i can't
let me have it you should have let me
have it i'd have posted the damn thing
on the podcast page i know and we could
have really
here's the things i well i want to wait
potentially as a
as an option to do that in the future oh
okay i don't want to ruin what i was
going to do yeah yeah sure for the
viewers
this strategy we were on the strategy
but we came up with a strategy to try to
because because they're on to you now
they're on to you because when they see
you post one of these things they're
like ah that [ __ ] thing's fake what
you should do is just keep a
notification on her account that way as
soon as that son of a [ __ ] comes out
you you put it on your account like it's
native just to make it
just so everyone's like well wait a
second gabe sanchez posted the same one
what the hell is going on that's what we
should do just jack with him a little
bit yeah yeah no for sure we always like
to piss in the cheerios a little bit
this is yeah you know it's uh the fun
part about the show yeah well uh how
much more time do you do you have any
more time or you you you're probably
like five minutes and i got like five
minutes okay so let's talk a little more
about
um this week's
uh uh
bonehead madness so we get so so tell
tell everyone um
what what we're coming down to what's
going to be the
the deal here for tomorrow because
tomorrow we're going to announce the
winner correct tomorrow we are going to
announce the winner and we will do a
follow-up uh i will i will launch the
poll in a moment for this
bonehead madness and then we will uh
have the poll up for the actual normal
weekly uh
uh bonehead of the week
all right so so this afternoon we'll
have we'll have the semi-finals
between what's what's the semi-finals
that we got going the semifinals we've
got tucker carlson and ron desantis
tucker carlson and ron
desantis
and then we'll get the uh the bonehead
of the week
um poll so so either it's though the
champ is either going to be tuckhams
or desantis
so we'll find out tomorrow in the second
hour of the tony michael's podcast
so don't miss tomorrow you're definitely
going to want to watch tomorrow tomorrow
i'm going to be full of bonehead
bonehead bonehead bonehead bonehead
is gonna be is gonna be full on bonehead
tomorrow so don't
miss tomorrow's episode so go to the
youtube channel and subscribe to the
youtube channel you don't wanna miss it
tomorrow second hour we will announce
who the bonehead champ is whether it's
tuckham's tucker carlson our governor
ron desantis that that bigot down in
florida
so stay tuned for that tomorrow like
subscribe and go to at toni michael's
pod that's where the polls and the games
will be
and we will be right gabe thanks for
joining us and thanks for all the
evidence hey and again everyone out
there
tag rick wilson i will get him on the
show yeah you get rick on the show get
him on the show let's talk about
politics and talk politics and i'll have
a whole hour segment about this yeah
we'll talk we'll talk bonehead madness
heist everyone stick around we're gonna
have rachel bitcover right after these
messages don't go anywhere you're going
to want to stick around rachel bitcoffer
is coming right after these messages
stick around we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us through the
break
we have to dock with us dr rachel
bit a golfer
one of our favorites here i'm tony
michael's vodkas
i'm not sure exactly what she wants to
talk about today but by god we're gonna
talk about it
how are you rachel
man that was funny as [ __ ] dude that
gave sanchez guys a funny [ __ ] guy
any tony yeah oh he's hilarious he is
hilarious did you did you catch the last
segment uh so so we did we're doing this
uh bonehead madness uh gabe came up with
this bonehead madness where we're doing
a bracket system of all the boneheads
this week we've been playing games all
on twitter it's been a big deal
i can't believe this dude i hate my job
like you know it's so serious and i have
to stay mission focused so i can't i
don't have time to do [ __ ] bonehead
bracket
well
here's the thing you can vote you can
vote on our podcast page today
and the guest guess who the semi-final
is for the championship it's tucker
carlson and ron desantis oh man
that's the go vote
i know i know so go choose and then
tomorrow on the show second hour when we
do bone end of the week we're going to
announce who the who the champ is for
bonehead madness but here's the thing
and you know rick wilson that lincoln
project you know you know that you know
those folks over there lincoln yeah yeah
yeah i don't know
i should be disclosing i you know i
might know them from such episodes as
having served on the board of lincoln
project yeah sure
so the lincoln project seems to have
stole our bonehead madness idea in a
video that they recently did
and gabe they've also they also lifted a
couple ideas of gabes and videos that
in this episode we would love to have
rick on to talk about it politics and
that but there seems to be
a hornet's nest so you know what i'm
gonna do what are you gonna do do what i
tell people to [ __ ] do i'm gonna
pivot and attack no i'm just kidding
the [ __ ] subject dude so tell
me what if i'm missing the headlines
today from the show
well um you know there's a lot of stuff
in the headlines but you know maybe
maybe one thing we should talk about
because
down in florida i'm not sure if the
republicans are more upset
that they that they actually
successfully passed a bigoted bill like
they don't say gay bill or it's just
that democrats won the messaging on that
bill because democrats did not win
uh ron desantis did sign that bill now
whether that bill will stay in the law
or not you know it's questionable um
who will find it constitutional or not
but democrats really want the messaging
on that thing because one time number
[ __ ] one let me i just keep trying to
make this point i just got out of a
meeting where i was making this point
not i'm picking on the person i was
meeting with or anything unrelated but
here's the [ __ ] point guys
like
the politics you have to win the
politics and have the power to win the
policy right the reason you guys lost
the policy in florida is you don't have
the [ __ ] numbers it doesn't mean the
politics didn't work doesn't mean you
didn't win that match but you have to
that and that is of course tony i know
you 100 agree with me the difference
between politics and policy and you know
that is a classic example of yes we lose
the policy but we never had a chance of
it winning any just like impeachment
fights the republicans are never gonna
do the right [ __ ] thing
but if the campaign helped brand them in
an unfavorable way
to conversion poll voters
and pissed off the base it's a [ __ ]
win for us right and it's one we should
be exploiting at every turn well and i
agree and i think we should be looking
um us as democrats and i'm i don't mean
big d democrats i mean
pro-democracy people because i know i
don't think that people are voting for
democrats that are like card-carrying
democrats at this point um there's a lot
of people out there that are going to
vote for democrats that don't
necessarily identify identify as
democratic party member right like they
don't walk around like that but there is
only one party that isn't trying to
ostracize people isn't trying to take
away rights from people who wants to get
right
what you want to do is you want to paint
a picture of an apocalyptic future
america under republican control where
it doesn't it's not just about not
extending equal rights anymore it's now
about persecution i mean that's what
they aspire to tucker carlson has made
that clear the reason he most admires
putin he has said is because putin
[ __ ] kills and jails gay people okay
so it's not just about taking back the
equality movement their intent to
recriminalize that [ __ ] so people should
be told what's coming you know in in the
in a oh [ __ ] scenario who are they going
to come after first the trans community
they've already done that and the lgbtq
plus community okay and then they'll
come for the opposition so like
to me
we need to be making it clear not only
to gay community um and activist members
but to every person that cares for their
health and well-being
their liberal lives are on the ballot
this fall well and
and the thing is is that they're going
to bleed this stealing of liberty i mean
they've already tried to steal the
liberty away from women in several
different states and they're going to
continue to do that they're stealing the
liberty away from lgbtq plus community
members you don't think they'll come for
your liberty too i mean that's the rub
no [ __ ] they're [ __ ] sending cdc to
people's houses in texas who helped
their children embrace their gender
identity
right and calling it child abuse okay
they're using the power of the state to
come and steal people's children from
making the mistake of loving them too
[ __ ] much guys so do
you clear eyed about who you're up
against
right and there and and and they're not
going to stop the just just at those
communities they're not going to stop
there as long as you let them get away
with it and they're like hey well
now we can just do anyone who believes
in liberal policy at all like oh
oh someone who believes in climate
change you believe in climate change
guess what you can't say that in school
anymore and if you do say in school we
can get the child protective services to
come over to your house and take your
children because you're indoctrinating
your children and the climate change is
real you know i mean this is the stuff
right tony like a few weeks ago i point
i i posted up this this um guidebook for
great courses maybe maybe i shouldn't
have done that was just a little expert
fair use so i posted it up because it
talks about like what the nazis did in
terms of indoctrinating the youth right
they obviously and they outlawed all the
other youth orgs every [ __ ] one of
them except for the not the hitler youth
orgs for the boys and the girls okay
and then they went after the school
curriculum and it wasn't just about you
know nationalism adding more patriotism
they went and they [ __ ] with
everything they they taught is a core
curriculum that the nazis got put into
the curriculum in german schools and
places they controlled the curriculum
that disabled people cost too [ __ ]
much were too much of a cost burden and
therefore it was simply rational choice
to kill them all okay like that wasn't
overheaded guys like oh my god
well
and it's
and it's no more clear
that democrats can win this messaging
then what happened in florida with the
don't say gay bill because
what i find
just
laughable is when i post anything about
it uh the other day ron perlman did a
video basically he called
ron desantis a piece of [ __ ] right and i
reposted that on tick tock because he
posted on twitter i'm like ah everyone
on tick tock should be able to see this
um it's it's it's a very interesting
video
so i posted it and the number one
comment was
you need to read the bill it doesn't say
don't say gay in the bill and i'm like
holy [ __ ] and that was every comment
they were more upset
they were way more upset
that that democrats won the messaging
yeah then then then then why ron
pearlman was calling ron desantis a
piece of [ __ ] they're like they weren't
saying we're not fascist you're fascist
like that's their normal i'm rubber
you're glue what bounces off me sticks
to you right that's their trumpism
argument that's the fascism argument
that they do right but they couldn't
even handle that they're like uh you
need to read the bill and it sounded
real familiar what did it sound
here's what it sounds like this is
that's what happens all the time to
democrats democrats are always like read
the bill it doesn't say that
let me give you a whole a whole list of
facts of why you're wrong right no [ __ ]
dude and you know what they [ __ ] hate
when we flip [ __ ] around on them like
that right i mean that's what my whole
strategy's about so i'll get one like oh
man there's this like baseball crank guy
he [ __ ] hates it man he he knows
every time and and he's oh my that's not
correct and that's not technically true
and
like it just goes to show that if we
just go on offense
against these turn blossoms we will kick
their [ __ ] ass they have never been
attacked and when they do they do the
same [ __ ] that we do to ourselves so
it's clear this is a strategy that's
gonna work and i just wish i could get
more people into the idea of busting
some [ __ ] proverbial heads well you
know if if republicans which i'm sure
the rnc and republicans do if they run
political campaigns like they run true
social um we're not up against much
really um and really the only thing
we're up against is a messaging machine
that they have because that's truly
that's truly what they weaponize
every day all day and they never stop is
their messaging machine and they built
this machine over the last 40 years um
between roger ailes um and and some
others of course thank god roger and
rush limbaugh are dead there's no better
uh thing for our country than them to be
six foot under but we still have fox
news we still have all these stations
and we're not going to get rid of them
we have freedom of speech here you're
not going to get rid of these things you
know everyone says oh we're going to
boycott them into oblivion
the problem isn't that fox news and oan
and newsmax exist the problem is is that
people out there
don't have other uh messaging that
combat that messaging for them to
perpetuate and to
to for us to propagate i know propaganda
is a bad word
but it's not it's not a bad word well
tony it's accepting the reality so it's
not just i mean it's not like it would
be a lot [ __ ] better if we could get
rid of those things okay that would be a
huge one of the most important things we
could do right but we can't get rid of
them so we need to go to war with the
clay that we have and the tanks we
actually own and in so far as knowing
that we cannot eliminate their noise
machine then our strategic you know
advantage is to create our own right as
much as we can possibly replicate it and
on your broader point before i i have to
jump sure on your broader point
here's here's what i'll be arguing in
this op-ed about the midterms it is true
that the fundamentals are against us
it's a change election their change
we're not that's a hard truth okay and
because no one watches the news no one
pays attention to [ __ ] you haven't seen
any change in those numbers since
ukraine broke out and biden's handled it
masterfully it's done absolutely [ __ ]
nothing because no one in america pays
attention anything but the [ __ ]
themselves right so at the end of the
day
the fundamentals are on their side and
they're telling us a clear
story of what's coming but and this is a
big but and i hope that you can rift off
this when i take off the politics are on
our side
they have given us a [ __ ]
arsenal to deploy against them met
they're gonna end social security and
medicare raise everybody's taxes and end
democracy i cannot think of a better
[ __ ] toolkit to go to war on you know
someone said this morning that if this
is a race about change
then we need to disqualify the change
someone said that this morning
this morning that was me it was it was
you i i featured the tweet earlier so
wow
very appreciate all your tweets so thank
you thank you doc
dr
rachel
thank you very much everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
rachel
finickover dr rachel bittikover
he's always spot on isn't she
she knows the messaging she knows how to
go on offense
and to get these these fascists on
defense oh i still have her her branding
up there go follow rachel at
rachelbittagover
on the twitter machine
speaking of the twitter machine let's
get back to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends shall we
rachel said she wanted me to riff a
little bit
and today
is
a
hashtag you can use this hashtag
trans day of visibility
uh the present united states is
apparently
deemed a trans day as visibility i think
that's where this came from and it's
very very very important
that we
do not abandon
our friends in the lgbtq community
especially
the trans people of our country
it really is it really is sick and gross
that the gqp
the fascist regime that wants to take
over our country that wants to commit a
cheeto dust kangaroo coup grant it a
soft one as opposed to the the hard one
that they attempted on january 6 with
burner phones qrfs
and eastman memos
but they want to take over the house of
representatives do you think for a
minute
that
as soon as the gqp
takes over the house of representatives
if you let them take over the and i'm
saying you you're
everyone out there listening you're
you're responsible you have to go vote
you have to go vote and you have to get
other people to vote
that's your responsibility as an
american citizen at this point that's
our civic duty
do you think they're not gonna start
trying to pass
laws like they've done in texas in
florida in the house of representatives
think about that if they do what matt
gatz wants to do and take over the house
and make donald trump the speaker of the
house you don't think they'll have don't
say gay bills
you don't think they'll try to be
telling schools all around the countries
how
telling children that they can or can't
think a certain way
telling parents of children who are
trans or gay that you're you're a
criminal you're a criminal
you're a criminal because of how your
child identifies
not understanding what even gender is
sexualizing gender these republicans
sexualizing gender that's what they're
doing
that's what they continue to do they're
[ __ ] weirdos they continue to talk
about other people's genitalia in
bathrooms
it's [ __ ] weird
and it's weird that they're doing it in
states and local governments but imagine
for a minute
that they want to do it on the federal
level
in the house of representatives
now the good news is is we have jill
biden
sitting in the white house
and their delusional plan
to impeach joe biden which it is
delusional to install donald trump
is ridiculous
but it's not a matter of them
instituting it or not
folks
it's a matter of convincing people out
there that it's a good idea to institute
garbage
like the don't say gay bill
and their best argument because they're
really pissed off like i said they're
really [ __ ] pissed off
they're really really really really
[ __ ] pissed off
the democrats won the messaging on the
don't say gay bill just go to any
[ __ ] comment section anywhere they're
like it doesn't say those words and that
bill it doesn't have to say the [ __ ]
words in the bill
for us to know what the intent is yeah
if you read the bill you know what the
intent is
dumb [ __ ]
it really is your intent is to take away
someone's liberty
and that's always their intent with
everything
i mean what other [ __ ] what other
[ __ ] platform do they have other than
taking away people's liberty
tell me show me
show me what the republicans platform is
on taxes
anymore
they don't have one
what about health care
they they threaten for years to get rid
of health care and we'll replace it with
what
tell me what their tell me what their
stance was
on infrastructure it was to not do
anything
to not have infrastructure we don't want
infrastructure spending
oh and by the way
you know if there's a pandemic and we
don't want to do that either [ __ ]
them what is their policies what do they
stand for they don't stand for anything
they stand against things
and it's mainly other human beings
liberty
to have their freedom their rights and
their pursuit of happiness
pursuit
of happiness
plastic martyr here says happy hashtag
trans day visibility to all my beautiful
trans brothers and sisters
shine bright
you are seen
don't listen to any of the hate from the
bottom feeders
they are beneath us we
belong
here
and you are beautiful and you are human
and if we do not protect those
who these people want to strip away
their liberty
they
will come for your liberty
next
that's what they will do
that is their goal
so stand
for trans day of visibility
stand for your trans brothers and
sisters your community members
your lgbtq community
women's rights to their uterus and the
liberty to their bodies
because when they come after them
they will not stop there
they will come after your liberty
earl
who says oh it doesn't say that in that
bill
those words are not in that bill
did you read the bill the intent to the
bills to take away someone's liberty not
to not say gay
they weren't banning a word
it doesn't say that they're just trying
to take away someone's liberty for
crying out loud geez louise get it
straight
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
all right let's go to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends there are a few
things i want to iron out here
uh maxine waters apparently there's a
video going around at maxine waters
and i haven't watched the whole thing
maybe we'll go ahead and watch it
let's find see if we can oh here it is
here it is
maxine waters is talking to some
homeless people that is gathered in san
francisco and apparently she apparently
she tells them to go home
let's iron this out
another another location where they're
taking after are there any more
locations than this one it might have
been so many people
[Music]
nothing is going to happen anymore today
what we're gonna well that's
what can you think
that's why they came out here today i
made them come out mm-hmm
and you need to know why they're failing
because blanca jimenez repeated we gave
her several meeting requests for you
concerning this and lassa for years
there's nobody in washington who works
for their people
harder than i do i believe i don't
okay so that clearly this is a video of
maxine waters getting into a uh this is
this is what actually is called blue uh
political discourse right this is maxine
waters
maxine waters going to where the problem
is now republicans are tearing her apart
because she said don't go home to the
homeless which is a little insensitive
for maxine waters but here's the thing
maxine waters
is right at where the heart of the
problem is maxine waters is going down
and talking to these people she's
conversing with them she isn't holding
fundraisers for two thousand dollar
plates here that's not what she's doing
yes is she receiving criticism right in
front of her absolutely
absolutely
why shouldn't we hold
representatives accountable whether it's
maxine waters or madison cawthorne
with the coke-filled orgies
here here is maxine waters going down
to try to help
a housing authority
get a situation corrected with homeless
people and home and home vouchers for
homeless people
and they're like oh she's insensitive
i mean yes is maybe maybe were some of
her words insensitive
were maybe her actions and sensitive
sure absolutely but she's not she's not
on a podcast talking about how lying or
whatever the [ __ ] lying telling the
truth who the [ __ ] knows about the coke
fueled orgies
she's not running around to [ __ ] town
halls spewing [ __ ] nazi propaganda
she's going to the heart of the problem
and yeah it's tough
it's tough democracy is [ __ ] hard
folks
it's not easy
it's not easy for maxine waters to snap
her fingers and appropriate funds for
these people standing there on the
street it's not that easy
but for these people the pressure maxine
waters they're probably correct
to make sure that she understands when
she goes back to washington when she
goes back that she has a say in
committees to appropriate funds
for housing authorities around the
country to make sure that they have the
funding for vouchers to make sure
homeless people have a warm place to
sleep and food to eat
we are in [ __ ] the united states of
america
we are in the [ __ ] united states
of america in 2022
and we think that it's a good idea
we think that it's a good idea
to to
to use the homeless
as a political weapon as the right is
doing here maxine waters is not using
the homeless as a political weapon she's
going down and she's talking to him
she's conversing with them she's their
congress person she's in front of them
and yeah me again she was maybe
insensitive with some of her comments
but she's having political discourse
with her constituents
who expect to get appropriated funds so
they can sleep in a warm bed
how in the [ __ ] in this country is it so
goddamn controversial
that someone have a place to sleep and
food to eat
how in the [ __ ] did we get into a
situation
where
the the ones who claim to be the
christian the most
which
god if if jesus was here
in this crowd with maxine waters
he definitely wouldn't be no [ __ ]
republican would he
it's high time we get our [ __ ] together
in this country and realize
that one one way we help the homeless
is is give them a home
yeah a place to sleep some food to eat
i'm not talking about
buying them an 800 000 mansion
they're human [ __ ] beings people
they're human beings
they deserve dignity
and if we give someone just a little bit
of dignity
a little bit of dignity and a little bit
of mental health care and health care in
general
in this country
we could probably help the homeless
problem
and almost 100 percent
get rid of it
because you know how you get rid of 100
of homeless people
you give them you give them a home
you give them dignity
dignity to sleep in a bed
dignity to eat food
to survive
these people aren't asking for for
[ __ ]
teslas
and mcmansions
or property
they simply want a place to sleep and
some food to eat
and we know we know
that that health care in this country is
a big cause for homelessness
on the mental on the mental health side
we know that
and we need mental health care in this
country stat
stat for a lot of different reasons
a hell of a lot of [ __ ] reasons
and for the right to take this video of
maxine waters
saying a couple insensitive things
and acting like she's against homeless
people listen do you think trump
do you think donald trump
would go anywhere near
a group of homeless people
do you think mitch mcconnell would be
caught
dead conversing and talking about
appropriations of funds to a housing
authority
to a group of homeless people in
kentucky [ __ ] no
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
so to criticize maxine waters
for going to her constituents
and trying to find out
what the problem is
to criticize her for saying some incense
to the thing we can criticize her for
saying something it was really a stupid
thing to say go home to homeless people
that really is a dumb [ __ ] thing to
say
it's ridiculous
but you wouldn't catch ted cruz
not in a million [ __ ] years
going
to a group of homeless people who are
having a challenge appropriating funds
for the housing authority to make sure
homeless people have a place to sleep
and have dignity human
[ __ ] dignity
you wouldn't catch him in a million
years
talking to a group of homeless people
not in a million [ __ ] years
so before you before you start slamming
maxine waters you [ __ ] republicans
and anyone else out there for that
matter
and again we can challenge her words
we can challenge her in sensitivity and
they did a very damn good job of it
right there
right there in in the political
discourse that was happening
everyone is scared of this little this
this maxine waters thing because the
insensitive things that she said i am
not scared to comment on it
i am not scared to give you the
messaging that needs to be told
because the reason why the republicans
are pouncing on this is because they
they [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] about
homeless people
they could care [ __ ] less about
homeless people
they don't give a [ __ ] they wouldn't
appropriate funds
for people that have human dignity
[ __ ]
they would never do that i mean unless
the
the person you know gave you know
several million dollars to their
campaign
or maybe owned a big corporation that
gives republicans money then they might
then they might think about
appropriating funds for that person's
human dignity
but someone who has mental health
challenges
who's have who's have a a drug addiction
which is not a crime it's a [ __ ]
health care problem
that's right
addiction is not a crime
we should stop criminalizing addiction
stop it
some of these people who are addicted to
drugs
it's a health care problem not a crime
problem
we have
we have to get our [ __ ] [ __ ] straight
and it's difficult it's difficult
as you pro-democracy folks know out
there i don't i don't say that this is
going to be easy this is not going to be
easy it's going to be very difficult
to beat these fascists in 2022.
but we have we have a way we have the
messaging
we just have to get behind the messaging
and push as hard as we can and lean into
democracy
like your life depends on it
people will follow you don't think that
the the generic ballot
as rachel talks about
the generic ballot in the suburbs
will follow you god damn right they will
you god damn right they will they didn't
they did in 2020. there was eight
million more votes
for joe biden than donald trump and i
don't believe that 81 million people
voted for joe biden
81 million people
some of them voted for joe biden but a
lot of them voted
against fascism
against it against the [ __ ] against
the chaos and we have the the former
president states colluding with russia
out in the open colluding with them
asking asking putin again
to find
to find emails or a laptop or whatever
the [ __ ] receipts checks i don't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about he was told to say that [ __ ] like
i said yesterday on the show yesterday
go check it out it's on the youtube
channel it's on all the directories go
download that son of a [ __ ] i did a
whole rant on it yesterday
about the video
about the video of him
fraternizing with putin
colluding with putin
go check that out
listen
it's gonna be difficult it's gonna be
hard
but they're giving us everything they
need
they love the murderous dictator putin
it's no more clear now than ever that
donald trump wants to be putin he wants
to be kim jong-un
and we see ron desantis and we see other
states trying to out florida florida
with with
texas missouri idaho and on and on it
will go
on and on it will go
and they will give us everything they
need to win the 2022 midterms
to beat back
fascism
okay let's take one more quick break
let's take one more quick break and then
we will um we will continue
we will be right back right after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
let's go through some more tweety tweets
and trendy trends shall we
we shall we shall we shall we shall
thanks for joining us here you know our
show is live every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch and now on the
midas touch facebook page thank you for
everyone joining us on facebook all the
new listeners from facebook have been
joining us you can also download the
podcast after we're done so here's what
happens we do it live every single
weekday two hours two
one
two full hours
and then after that i download it and
upload it and reload it and put it on
the interwebs
and then boom you can go download
you can go download on apple spotify
google all your favorite directories and
while you're there downloading this
episode of the tony michael's podcast
on your favorite directory leave us a
five star review
not a four star nine there a five star
review
give us a good review over there that
helps us out in those algorithms
those things that are the rhythms of the
owls i don't know
algs
algorithms i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure how it works
like subscribe you know all the stuff
i'm supposed to say for um
for youtube go down in the comment
section below and
leave us a comment and all that kind of
good stuff if you're on facebook like us
follow us i don't know
get confused there's so many channels
you subscribe on some you follow on
others you like on i don't know
it's all confusing to me
it's all confusing but you know whatever
whatever station
socials interwebs that you're on
do the thing that you do there
to help us out retweet like share
there's a whole list of things that
you're supposed to do on social media
okay let's go back to the trendy trends
and tweet tweets devin nunes is trending
because social media um
excuse me truth social media sucks
and it sucks to suck
uh following report from the rap
the former president's trump social
media app
true social has reported a 93 decline in
signups
oh [ __ ] i guess when the app doesn't
work people stop signing up for that son
of a [ __ ] um some discuss the fact that
devin nunes left the seat in congress to
run its rollout yeah devin nunes is a
dumb ass here now what does john collins
say john says devin nunes will never be
as popular as his cow
actually i think i think um because gabe
i think actually um we went through this
on an episode
when they first did the roll out of true
social he kind of explained some of the
things about how they copied the source
code and they copied a lot of different
things from true social and how it
worked and how it operated all that kind
of good stuff
and the craziest part about some of this
is
that they they literally they literally
didn't do much but devin nunes
apparently when he left his
congressional seat and went over a ceo
or whatever the fall guy for the uh for
the pump and dump that is true social
and you know he's eventually going to be
the fall guy for this probably in a
federal criminal court but devin nunes
uh he
he he was trying to make sure that there
could be no account you know it's
supposed to be the place where you can
you know you can do anything you want
you can do anything you want on social
media on true social but apparently you
cannot make an account that says nunez
and cow in it
i guess they were trying to get the app
to where it would manage to where you
couldn't say you couldn't make an
account that had the words nunes and cow
in it
i don't know amy lynn says here
and devin nunes is as good at running
true social as he wasn't
suing a fake cow
you know that he had a big feud with
devin nunes cow right uh here on here on
twitter
yeah he tried to sue
i don't know why i guess he he thought
it was impersonating his verified cow or
something i have no idea
i have no idea of course everyone's
piling on don lewis's people are saying
devin nunes has
excuse me
people are saying that devin nunes is
having a cow
about the true social debacle
uh no pun intended i'm sure don thank
you very much for your tweet um
oh these are gonna be good these cow
jokes are gonna be good and mayo said
this was a couple days ago mayo said i'm
starting to think devin nunes quit
congress to help trump launder money
through true social and we i think we i
think we read this one earlier didn't we
didn't i give credit earlier nope thank
you mayo for your tweet
thank you thank you thank you now
hoodlum here says devin nunes is throw
it
i can't get my zoom right
i'm going too fast
devin nunes is threatening to personally
sue anyone for dumping
truth social so he's threatening anyone
even a cow
if you're dumping true social and gabe
actually tried to sign up for this thing
and i had like a waiting list
i don't know if you guys remember that
they had a waiting list and it would
like show you
what how much how where in line you were
like what number and line you were he
never moved
never moved at all
tim says devin nunes left congress to
run cry space
[Laughter]
that's literally what it would be over
there right if it actually gets up and
running which it won't
because apparently the problem here is
that they can't get money
right they did this spak thing
and uh for anyone who doesn't know what
a spec is
um it's a fancy way of financing
a company
that doesn't really own anything sort of
um there's several different episodes
where we talk about a spec
um but the
the long of the short of it is is that
this was a way for trump to fill his
pockets worth of money and steal the
money got it
okay
you good you good with that you go with
that explanation it's a pump a dump
it's a pump and dump scheme he got all
his supporters to pump their money into
it and then they dump their stocks
when it was high and they sold and they
pocketed the money and now they don't
give a [ __ ] if this thing takes off or
not they don't care they done left with
their money
because this morning i said true social
[ __ ] gevin nunes diaper
devin nunes left his congressional seat
to become
the [ __ ] fall guy for true social uh
aunt crabby calls [ __ ] says
i might zoom i'm just off today
we're 49 minutes in the hour we got
about 10 minutes left
for use out there accountants on the
clocks
but aunt crabby says pro tip never take
care advice
from devon newton's
oh [ __ ]
they're broke when you know it trump's
broke true socials broke they're all
[ __ ] broke broke broke broke broke
broke good for them we're happy for him
this is why me and rachel are telling
you guys dr rachel bittikov or telling
you guys that hey
we got all the tools we need they're
giving them all of them
they're giving us all the weapons we
need to fight against fascism in 2022
and smash it into oblivion
like i believe we can make this election
count so hard
that trumpism may just fade off into the
distance for 2024 well it may not fade
off into the distance but it'll be
deemed irrelevant
that's what liz cheney and adam
kinzenger are trying to do in the
january 6th select committee they're
trying to take their party back
that's what they're trying to do in hell
with this war in ukraine
the the party is more divided now than
ever
as as as the former guy the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants is colluding
with putin out out in the [ __ ] open
calling for him to find emails or a
laptop or a check or a paycheck or
i don't know a bank i don't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about he
was told to say that he was given the
script to say that [ __ ]
they're giving us all the tools they
need folks
and really honestly are you going to not
mention this when someone says oh well
what do we want we want republicans
running our schools you want the
republicans to run your schools the same
people who can't get a [ __ ] copy
pasted social media site up and running
that's who you want running your [ __ ]
school board
that's it you want running your state
legislator you want the [ __ ] party of
the guy who's colluding with putin who's
murdering women and children who's a
murderous dictator
who who [ __ ] executes dissidents
that's what you want
what are you talking about this is real
easy stuff folks real easy stuff because
that's what they're gonna do to you
that's what they're gonna do you you
heard rachel today say we need scorched
earth
scorched earth messaging
well that's what you're going to get
here for me okay let's see what else is
on the trendy trends because we get uh
we got about nine minutes left in the
show
well it's here caitlyn jenner is
trending
um oh fox news hired her as a
contributor oh oh well
um
there there's there's your news on
caitlyn jenner
uh ivor mekhten is in the news
uh we heard yesterday that they're
they're approving a fourth
uh shot of another booster shot for
pfizer and moderna for people over 50
and immune compromised folks out there
but ivormectin's in the news this
morning a clinical study has found that
the anti-parasitic drug ivermectin
does not reduce the risk of covet
hospitalization
it doesn't do it and showed no sign of
alleviating the disease according to the
new york times
um you know they screamed all last year
oh
why isn't why isn't big pharma trying to
figure out why ivermectin does or does
not work
for covid big pharma was like last year
was like well that's not how iver mechan
works number one
that's not how it works
number one
number two we did do a study here's the
study you people are a bunch of
dumbasses
and should have been listening to us the
whole time as opposed to listening to
facebook
the facebook ivermectin institute
jesus
kate says a large clinical trial found
that i remembered and failed as a cova
19
treatment
because it's [ __ ] horse dewormer
it's a dewormer folks
it's a dewormer
and everyone kept you know they kept
just saying this in the comments oh it's
won the
the nobel prize and it's won this and
it's got this and it's great for this
yeah for worms
it's it's that's the other thing it was
approved in the united states it's fda
approved in the united states
it's an fda approved drug
yeah for worms
for worms
and they were eating horse-based at one
point
because the most prevalent form of
ivermectin
was in animal dewormer
because it makes a really good dewormer
for animals
like it's a really good [ __ ] dewormer
for animals especially livestock
that we may or may not eat
that we eat as food
it works really well
as a dewormer because that's
what it is
and the uh the
the prescribed version of ivermectin
has only one fda use that is approved
and it's for
a worm
and it's for a worm that doesn't live
here it doesn't exist here the worm that
ivermectin is approved for is for a worm
that doesn't exist here in this country
and the reason why it doesn't exist is
because we know where it exists and we
know what drug helps to make sure that
people who go to that region
do not return with that worm it's called
ivermectin
and doctors prescribe ivermectin for
people who are going to that region or
have come from that region for
that specific worm look the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
pluck your head out of your is people
really still eating horse paste
are they really still at this point
running down to the [ __ ] feed store
and gobbling up [ __ ]
sheep drench
they were drinking sheep drench at one
point because it has ivermectin in it i
don't know if you know this but
uh sheep you know they have parasites
and they're wool
and
down at the feed store like tractor
supply or you know your local livestock
kind of store
they gotta they got a bottle down there
it's called sheep drench
and it's got ivermectin is one of the
active ingredients in it
because ivermectin is really good at
getting rid of parasites
it's specifically a parasite that
happens to live inside the
the wool
of a sheep so what you do i don't know
if you guys have ever given a dog a flea
bath before
but you pour this [ __ ] into it into a
drench and you drench
the sheep the livestock with this [ __ ]
and it gets rid of the parasites
people were drinking that [ __ ]
i'm not i'm i'm not making this stuff up
i mean they're drinking their piss why
not drink the sheep drench jesus christ
that papa what does an old castler say
here
no casler says science
large clinical trial shows ivermectin
doesn't cure covet
joe rogan quote
but did they take it from
did they take it with el jerky though
i don't know if that's an actual quote
from joe rogan i think noel may be
making a joke there
you guys remember the joe rogan debacle
with aaron rodgers well just himself too
you know where he was talking about ivor
mechtin and he was taking all these
drugs when he had coven and he's
fantastic now and all this [ __ ]
oh my lord okay let's go back to tweet
tweets we are 57 minutes into the hour
we got a few minutes left let's see what
else is trending
oh did we watch the trump cover-up video
uh i don't think we did let's watch this
video real quick it's 49 seconds let's
watch this minus touch video about the
seven hour gap in the phone logs
breaking news on the investigation into
the january 6 assault on the capital cbs
news and the washington post have
obtained white house records of
president trump's activities that day
and they reveal a nearly eight-hour gap
in entries in his call log and his daily
diary last call is recorded at 11 17 and
it's to an unidentified person extremely
vague the next call recorded occurred at
6 54 pm this gap raises big questions
about what the president was doing at
the time and whether he was using a
so-called burner phone maybe a couple of
them those are disposable and
untraceable what is he hiding and what
is he trying to cover up who is he
trying to protect
hashtag trump cover-up
breaking news on
go go spread this around this video
around like herpes
not just on this on this platform but
all platforms
hashtag trump cover-up let's see what
else do we have here we are 58 minutes
into the second hour we got two minutes
left remember
don't forget subscribe to the youtube
channel we really welcome all the new
listeners out there all the new
listeners on the fight
on that midas facebook page not the
fighters facebook page the midas
facebook page
you know we broadcast every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch follow
us there
at tonymichaelspod on twitter
see the broadcast there also don't
forget to vote for bonehead madness
today the semi-final between tucker
carlson and ron desantis i wish i had
like a
sound effect but i don't
so go go vote at tony michael's pod on
the semifinal for bonehead madness also
don't forget to uh
to let lincoln project know
there might have been a lift might have
been a theft go let them know that
but follow us follow us also
on twitch if you're on twitch youtube
and the midas facebook page you can go
to thetonymichaels.com all of my social
medias are there you can follow us there
don't forget again
to vote for the bonehead madness
championship between tucker carlson and
ron desantis and also be watching be
watching for the bonehead of the week
poll we will have that out and tomorrow
in the second hour like we do every
single friday in the second hour we go
through your vote your vote for bonehead
of the week and the bonehead madness
tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central we'll see you
then until then surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking